هل يمكنك تعلم التمارين التي أقوم بها
حبيبي لأنني أفعل ذلك يوميًا
إنه يساعد كثيرًا ليس فقط في حياة المرء
رياضي أو تعليم أي شخص
أريد أن أفعل هنا أريد أن أشعر أنني بحالة جيدة
في اليوم الذي تكون فيه بصحة جيدة
جيد أعتقد أن هذا يساعد كثيرا
ضد الحبوب ستفعل مختلفة إذا حصدت
ما النبات لاختيار الثعبان بشكل جيد
زراعة الأشهر المفضلة مع المغادرة
يحدث في لأن هذا هو المكان الذي أعتقد أنه
أصعب
ولكن في نفس الوقت أعتقد أنه كذلك بالنسبة لي
ماذا احتاج المزيد من حفيد لكوني
رياضي استبدال الجسم في نهاية
تجد السيطرة
غادر مايكون داريا دانيال ألفيس في قارب و
ويلينغتون هو الماعز لأنه رجل
التي أنا معجب بها كثيرًا لكوني رياضيًا
مستوى عال لسنوات عديدة
كان الهدف الرئيسي من الأصدقاء الرائعين في
كرة القدم
نبرة صوت النظام وصديق ايضا
أنا شخص مميز لأعرف من أنت
الذي فاجأني كثيرا وأصبح
ليس فقط نفس الطعام
الهدف هو التدريب بشكل أفضل كل يوم
العب بشكل أفضل
efe مساعدة زملائي في الفريق
لذلك هذا ما أريد أن أكون فيه
الأرض دائما أفضل شيء
مثل